bon j'ai pas le temps d'attendre he moi
mais écoutez le perchem n'est pas là tu
te rends compte mais c'est une
plaisanterie ça allez tournons
AR qu'est-ce qu'il fut ce qu'est-ce que
tu fous là-bas viens là nom de Dieu oh
mais qu'est-ce que tu allé
là-haut allez m dans 30 secondes on
raccorde absolument allez moteur
allons-y Meur vas-y vas-y Jean-Pierre
moteur moteur allons-y
monst oui je pense que c'est un des
rares métiers on peut insulter enfin il
y a plein de comportements qui seraient
qui seraient acceptés dans sur aucun
dans aucune autre entreprise je pense je
pense qu'on peut faire des grands films
sans sans mettre une tension énorme et
sans être violent et sans maltraiter les
gens alors là moi c'est quelque chose
qui m'est absolument insupportable donc
non il y a rien qui justifie rien du
tout